citizens of the reject Nation we've
changed the tire because we're here for
another James gun thinking images
Guardians of the Galaxy they've got a
full trailer here for the next
installment of phase five after Ant-Man
of the Lost quantumania heads up our
review for quantumania will be going up
uh on Tuesday you know what koi I'm
gonna see it Monday you should uh let's
do one for the channel too we'll do a
non-spoiler one I got you yeah well
let's get to you know what to do make
sure you go ahead leave a like koi
undoubtedly will be the experts in this
video for sure so let's see what's going
on
foreign
love
that girl died but then she came back
came back a totaled dick oh please he
left out some important information but
that is the gist of it
oh I love these movies let's play a Name
Game
I'll wait
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
yes evolutionary he didn't want to make
things perfect oh
just hated things the way they are
huh
oh interesting I'm talking to tie her to
that
2000 fun
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to if I beside my friends
nice Warlock
is that Lila so cool
it is and how we found each other
cool it actually looks awesome ready
one last ride
dude tracks man so worried about you
dude I know I don't want him to fly away
together
to the forever
and beautiful sky
I get the impression they're looking for
the high evolutionary
well there's that one scene with the
wait a second that whoever it was that
you were in love with it sounds more
like her hers do not bring me into them
knock it off
how black your eyes were they were
replaced by my father as a method of
torture he he picked a pretty set
oh God I was like are we gonna change
him Falling in Love by conversation I
ship them immediately I've seen I mean
I've been saying Karen's MVP of this
franchise and if that happens I'm in I
really like the trailer because what it
demonstrated was more of the fun side as
comparative to the last trailer which
had some fun in there at the beginning
but then went full on emotional this had
to good blend of the array of the
emotions that you would sort of want
from it or the melancholic side but also
a lot of the humerus side to it as well
but what I said in the middle of it
about them looking for I always was
under the impression High evolutionary
came to them and from what it looks I
mean I'm not exactly sure why the
impression that I was getting was
they're looking for him and it sounds
like it might have something to do with
rocket I've always thought that they
were looking for him well I think I mean
it's very clear to me that rocket is a
creation of right yeah
here too I think that from the beginning
they've been trying to seek out what
Rocket's Origins are in a way like maybe
they need to solve like maybe he's hurt
or maybe he's poison like there's
something like an impetus right yeah
maybe he's the only one that can save
him because he built him yes so I'm
wondering with now tying that into it
looked like there was a shot where it
cut to nebula like immediately after
saying like he only wants to change
things so now I'm curious if maybe he
was like one or a few new Thanos like I
wonder if there's going to be a tie into
there was something happening there with
those creations and things that'd be an
interesting way to make the universe a
little tighter true true I mean it seems
like we got two plots here they're
looking for high evolutionary for some
purpose that has something to do with
rock because I don't imagine that it's
high evolutionary it's like I want my
rocket fast
raccoon it was the perfect day like it
doesn't seem like that's the case and
they seem to be showing a lot of imagery
of Rocket like dying or or being really
sick yeah that's why I'm getting
poisoned so that's why I was thinking
maybe they need to go to to him to maybe
help out rocket but it's not going to go
the way they would want it to go yeah
sure and and then they got the other
plot which is carrying over from
Guardians 2 the post-credits scene of
man this keeps happening to me what is
the name of the gold people in Guardians
too uh Aisha Sovereign The Sovereign
thank you John uh The Sovereign warlock
so you got like this one plot where
they're on the run and they got this
like beat this monstrosity coming after
them which is in the form of Adam
Warlock I don't know what's gonna come
of that and I still feel like Drax is
going to be I think Layla maybe tells
them about the acceleration area I
thought it was Lila this whole time it
might be I've only read it yeah nobody
read the comic to me but like her uh
maybe maybe she is the you know inciting
instant to get them on that Journey
because like you know we see them yes
yes
bottom line it doesn't seem like oh bad
guy showed up it seems like they're
looking for bad guy yeah like resting
across the cosmos and maybe like he's
pursuing them it'd be a cool like Chase
Dynamic like Adam warlock's pursuing
them while they're pursuing the high
evolutionary that'll give you a little
bit more flavor of intensity and then
Adam Warlock takes out the high
evolutionary well and maybe there's like
a yeah
yeah second this character shows up just
murkham uh maybe there will be like a
parallel plot line though because
there's a lot in here about you know
quill and Gamora and their whole you
know new report now that she is back in
a different iteration it's not like
before and then maybe you'll have like
the literal organic side of that with
rocket trying to reconnect with like the
one person aside from Groot who like
really knows him or who he really can
you know feels some type of
vulnerability with yeah I'm wondering
what will become of that with Gamora
because when I I don't feel like it
would go the direction that some of us
might want where this Gamora ends up
falling in love with Peter Quill I feel
like it's gonna be a new set of what is
the crew that comes after one of the
other Crews it's like adjacent to the
Guardians well they they introduced
another set of Guardians in the ravagers
at the end of Guardians yeah but I don't
think it'll be them I feel like it'll be
a new group but some of them from here
will stick for the future and I don't
feel like the moral part of that because
I think this will be yeah
um no I I think that you know I I feel
like Drax is gonna today Batista just
said too much I feel like I feel like
Jack's gonna die and I think Chris Pratt
too see that's what I mean if Chris
Pratt is going to die or he's gonna
leave guardians but he's gonna leave the
Guardians behind him like go on a
separate path because I don't feel like
Gamora will end up with them or maybe
she will I mean let's be the linear path
and I don't think James Gunn does linear
or maybe we're thinking about it because
of that and he's double double crossing
because this has to be the at the ending
Trilogy note and that's why I think like
this the follow-up to Guardians I don't
feel like the Guardians will completely
end I think there'll be a different
group of people that will still have
like rocket in there and Groot oh
Seattle
I feel like Rock's gonna live and
they're just that's why they're showing
us so much to get us to think he's gonna
die but I don't think he's gonna
actually die and I I wouldn't put it
past them to do that but at the same
time yeah I fee I keep getting the
feeling that Drax will go rocket will be
the big emotional death and then uh
maybe somehow quill and Gamora will ride
off into the sunset and do their thing I
don't think you figure two if you got
Drax who also died he'd be like the
Abrahams well then Walking Dead for you
guys like the Abraham to the to the
Glenn situation sure you'd be like
everyone would just think about like
like rocket no one would really think
about it because he dies halfway through
the film
my big question yeah they're like man
this is I'm so tired uh everyone's dying
but I I'm literally intrigued by Adam
Warlock being introduced softly in the
first one in the Cocoon right we've been
building Adam Warlock so I'm really
intrigued by it now using the high
evolutionaries kind of a duality that
Adam Warlock if you've got the high
evolutionary duplicitous one might say
uh no but I think I think the
interesting take on Adam Warlock is he
is the idea of perfection and then they
just said he isn't striving for
Perfection he just wants to change
things so it'd be very interesting if
they have a commentary on like what
Perfection is and what evolution is
versus what the evolutionary is actually
doing so you've got like the you know
the Nazis who experimented on people
like like the monsters they were being
what happened you know there's there's
things that had intentions but there's a
reason we brought in some of their
scientists
right guys we're all on the same time
being the Pure Evil and what that means
for Adam Warlock and how that relates
like what it is to achieve Perfection
what it is to perceive their being
Perfection because if there's ever a
team that is human it's the Guardians
even though if they're not all human
like so it's interesting to have that
duality of plot but has this time to the
DC Universe well you see James Gunn is
going to bring Chris Pratt over a
Star-Lord and then flash is going to
reset the universe he's gonna be at the
end of the movie and then all the cast
is going to be pulled in got it okay now
it all makes sense yeah absolutely it's
gonna be a what if episode that is the
amount of the universe we're gonna get
dark claw we're gonna get spider boy
we're gonna get all those characters
they're gonna split James Gunn is going
to be the one above all he's gonna have
a mustache like Stanley it's gonna be
very confusing he who remains stand gun
oh I feel like this one it will Top at
least the second one Guardians one is
the top of the top of the list for like
top five for Marvel for me for sure same
so I don't know exactly where this will
land this might be my favorite Trilogy
though when it's done I I I hope it does
that effect for me where okay yeah maybe
I'm I'm not a big fan of Guardians too
but I would like to watch this one and
go but as a Trilogy it's a perfect
package yeah yeah I want that effect
we're like going back in hindsight it
automatically elevates Guardians too for
me we'll see how it goes alrighty guys
well out of ten where'd you get the
trailer uh I mean I was immediately
invested like 9.6 I was enthralled sure
I'll meet you at 9.6 koi 11. all right
eleven trailers Ahoy please today's the
day alrighty guys well thank you for
being here I can't wait to watch this
movie and so yeah keep looking for Ammon
in the Lost quantumania coverage coming
up this week
it's a similar tone I suppose
I feel like not before we do this
Mark Leach mark my dude it's Super Bowl
Sunday here and uh you're in the UK I
don't think you give a about what's
going on right now nope so I figured you
were the perfect person to let feel
welcome here well I'll let you know as
two Americans John right now is wishing
he was with his family watching the game
and my family could not care any damn
about it I don't even care about it
never have never will I care more about
the Rihanna thing going on but I want to
say to you dude that I know 20 30 nope
23rd 2013 my years are off here
um I know that uh 2022 was a year
but I feel like this year you're gonna
really make it your own and I want you
to keep on doing that thing where you
are able to be vulnerable keep
connecting and you have a gift of
empathy and you have a gift to really
understand people at a deeper level and
also you are quite you're just a very
understanding individual so please keep
honing in on those qualities and just
amplify them even more because people
need that gift more and more the these
days so thank you so much for being you
and I'm hoping that uh it can be a more
optimistic perspective as you set forth
on this journey ahead of you buddy thank
you again for being here
[Music]